south of Newburgh is West Point where the
United States Military Academy is located
in the war for independence a military post
was established here to prevent the British
fleet from passing this point a huge chain was
stretched across the river part of the chain
used is on display here Tarrytown along
with North Terre town and Irvington are
in the region made famous in the Legend of
Sleepy Hollow written by Washington Irving
Sunnyside was the home of Washington Irving
from 1835 to 1859 the old Dutch Church in
North keraton built in 1685 is believed to be
the oldest on the Hudson in the Sleepy Hollow
cemetery by the church one of the graves is
that of Washington every day on its final
stretch the Hudson passes a city that to many
people symbolizes America New York City yes
it is the city with the tallest buildings in
the world it is one of the large cities with
the most people in the world the city with
its famous Broadway and 42nd Street one of
the entertainment centers of the world the city
with its Wall Street one of the financial centers
of the world and the city with the busiest
harbour in the world but it is also the city
that is the headquarters of the United Nations
mankind's hope for a better world with inside of
the city is a symbol which is America's answer to
mankind's eternal hope it's the symbol of a sweet
land of liberty and of its people who sing with
pride let freedom ring from every mountainside